bernard montiel bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là je vous en prie alors lui il a
tout le monde au téléphone
non mais sans et c'est un truc de fou
avant l'émission il a tout ay il est
très influent alors sachez le lui il
peut faire sauter des points soleil
c'est un truc les chéris sachez que
bernard montiel malheureusement bernie
je rappelle que j'ai gagné honnêtement
ma place et bien sûr contraire avoir
battu delambre l'habitabilité
donc voilà non je suis désolé j'ai
prévenu très vite parce qu'en fait j'ai
vraiment des rendez-vous sérieux que je
ne peux pas passer mon avis la défiance
du jeu j'ai payé mes séances d'uv d'
avance donc je suis obligée d'y aller
non non j'ai des rendez vous
professionnels très sérieux et voilà
donc pas de laponie pour moi en revanche
j'offre ma place ce soir aucun autre
elle est gentille l'appel du gentil
c'est pas pour ça que tu as long as i et
sur lequel il est sur ma bile ah non
mais son intérêt sur moi pas tu vas être
sûr et ça vous faire tout drôle de
chapeau à son couvercle un nom c'est une
réflexion du père noël est une ordure et
surtout
on va là sourire à droite comme à gauche
il ya un point soleil est ouvert jusqu'à
20 qu'une fois dire à défaut vraiment
bernard ne voient un défaut vraiment
aller bernard we need is in petit zizi
là d un vrai truc aller bernard si tout
allait bien mais c'est pas mal optimisé
on m'a dit qui apparemment il y aura pas
de combat
deux mondes hui mon pote je suis déçu
leur chante la salle malraux la balle
avait combien de caméras quand et à la
salle et avait des maquilleuses tout ça
la grand mère tu fais du cinéma ont
ralenti dans la salle de sport tas grand
mère m'a dit il y avait pas grand mère
qui s'était beaucoup dessus c'est vrai
nom mais lui ça doit être dans une
cabine à uv pour passer rien senti
on a mis ce collège donné le bail
alors moi quand je me balade dans la rue
j'aimerais bien pouvoir avoir le
superpouvoir de voir des gens à poil
bah ouais ouais ça me fait rire beaucoup
de voir les gens à poil les favoris
tuterai voyeur excusez moi il ya des
succès des noms mais sans réelle ou non
mais c'est vrai avec cette idée vous
êtes des taris dans cette bande au
témoin et moi ya le regard du siècle
c'est wesh wesh désastre catastrophe
dans ce groupe n'a ni queue ni tête qui
skieurs l'huile et la main il est plus
du tout bronzé un voyez je travaille
qu'est-ce qui va accueillir 20 yards en
sur rfm
franchement il alluma il après
franchement il a attendu 60 ans pour se
mettre à bosser
[Applaudissements]